[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
oh
le nintendo direct est enfin sorti et
bon sang quelle surprise
il est évident qu'une grosse annonce
allait être partagées mais je pensais
plutôt au prochain pokémon à la base je
vous avoue qu'avec ue et nm lt on
pensait déjà depuis un moment à faire un
épisode 2 sur ce match mais nous sommes
tellement épais qu'on a réellement
décidé d'en faire un autre mais tout
d'abord faisons un petit point sur ce
que nous avons dit nous avions raison
pour les inkling c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça qu'on en avait parlé en premier je
vous cache pas notre fierté
ensuite link de breath of the wild a été
annoncé nous savions qu'il en ferait
partie
mais est-ce un nouveau personnage ou
simplement un costume de link
après tout le trailer est là pour donner
envie personnellement nous gardons
toujours nos positions sur ce que nous
avons dit chaque personnage énoncé
pourrait être sur ce nouveau smash enfin
si ce n'est pas un simple portage mais
ça n'en a pas l'air du tout bon bref je
m'égare
il ya beaucoup de choses à dire mais je
garde ça plutôt pour la fin de la vidéo
concentrons-nous plutôt sur six autres
personnages du jeu vidéo qui pourrait
largement avoir leur place dans ce
nouveau smash your name ltée que la
pluie de théories commence
[Musique]
captain taudis pour moi il est largement
voire fortement possible que captain
todd fera partie du prochain smash mais
pourquoi ça cartonne est devenu un
personnage phare est récurrent de
l'univers de mario
il apparaît pour ses premières fois dans
super mario galaxy et devient très vite
populaire avec notamment la sortie d'un
jeu qui lui est dédié sur wiiu captain
toad treasure tracker le jeu est
sympathique frais et s'inspire des
petits niveaux créés dans mario 3d world
le personnage devient populaire dans
l'univers et on le retrouve partout
il est dans chaque monde de mario
odyssée et comme annoncé dans le
nintendo direct de portage de captain
blood arrive sur switch et 3ds avec de
nouveaux niveaux pour que je vous dis là
et pour bien vous faire comprendre que
captain toad est devenu un nikon de
mario il est devenu très populaire
je pense donc qu'il ya énormément de
chance pour le voir dans le prochain
smash malheureusement le problème serait
son gameplay
captain toad ne s'est pas sauter et
c'est ce qui freine l'idée ce dernier
pourrait se battre avec des outils
d'exploration comme une pelle et une
pioche n'importe
mais le fait de sauter dans ce match est
essentielle pour le gameplay alors
est-ce que captain taux de serait le
premier à adapter un gameplay
particulier sur le sol après tous les
persos de ce match commence beaucoup à
se diversifier
je pense à bayonetta ou corinne par
exemple ou bien aurait-il un gameplay
très avantageux sur le sol comme little
mac
je ne sais pas mais si captain taux de
fait partie du prochain smash
nintendo va devoir creuser dans
l'imagination à un personnage qui ne
vient pas de nintendo hershel layton
plus connu sous le surnom de professeur
layton est un personnage assez demandée
par les fans pour rejoindre le casting
de smash bros et même s'il a été créée
par l'entreprise lebel five on peut tout
de même pâté du doigt quelques arguments
en sa faveur
déjà la fidélité de la licence aux
consoles nintendo n'est plus à prouver
le célèbre archéologue a bien roulé sa
bosse sur ds et 3ds et non les sorties
que pour de rares occasions pour des
jeux édités sur smartphone
la licence professeur layton est associé
aux consoles portables nintendo
il est important de noter que le dernier
opus de smash bros avait compté sonic et
bâillonné talent son roster qui sont
comme pour lleyton des personnages de
licences très liés à la firme japonaise
si les développeurs de smash bros switch
veulent
doublez la chose il est très probable
que cela se fasse avec un personnage tel
que le professeur mais à ce moment là
plusieurs questions peuvent se poser
tout d'abord pourquoi privilégier layton
un personnage de duke iwatch autres
licences phares de level five dont les
jeux très populaires sont sur 3ds
et bien tout simplement pour la raison
suivante de kayes walsh n'est pas qu'un
jeu vidéo à la base il a été conçu dès
le départ comme une oeuvre cross média
on n'est pas dans le cadre de la licence
pokémon ou la série et les mangas sont
apparues suite au succès du premier jeu
dans ces conditions le professeur layton
semble plus désigné pour rejoindre le
casting de smash bros switch autre
question que pourrait faire la tonne en
tant que personnage il fait de l'escrim
ils fabriquent une mitrailleuse à pièces
dans l'opus professeur layton et le
destin perdu
il a deux passes défendre sinon c'est
pas compliqué il peut pointer du doigt
ça fait un smash et entre nous et
l'entraîneuse wifi tesquet second temps
normal et mister gay men watches bas
peut être un pardon désolé lundi
challenge sympathique de certains
personnages smash bros c'est le trouver
des façons de leur faire utiliser des
coups comme pour le villageois d'animal
crossing
si les développeurs ont pu trouver un
panel d'attac audio de kent croyez moi
quand je vous dis que c'est pas
professeur layton qui va leur poser
problème
pour finir j'aimerais vous dire que le
président de level five akihiro hino
avait été interviewé en 2009 sur un site
de jeux vidéo et qu'il avait confié que
la possibilité de faire deux échelles et
luc des personnages guest dans des jeux
comme mario kart smash bros serait
certainement une merveilleuse
opportunité
voilà que voulez-vous de plus tout
énigmes à une solution
souvenez vous en 2015 à travers un
scrutin public
nintendo a donné la possibilité aux fans
de voter pour le personnage qu'ils
aimeraient voir en dlc sur super smash
bros
au total 1,8 million de votes et
résultats
bayonetta a été choisi en majorité
malheureusement nous n'avons pas eu plus
de détails concernant les autres
candidats en lice
cependant plusieurs sondages réalisés
ont mis le personnage de king car roule
dans les premières places
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas c'est
un peu le buzzer de l'univers donkey
kong
c'est l'antagoniste principal est
l'ennemi juré de dca et ses alliés mais
le hic
la grosse différence avec bowser c'est
que king car roule a été délaissé sur
les derniers jeux de la licence il
n'apparaît dans super smash bros qu'à
travers les trophées à collectionner et
ceux déjà depuis mai l'équipe d'ailleurs
la petite anecdote rigolote autour de ce
personnage c'est que sa description dans
mail et le présente comme un méchant qui
n'a pas été en mesure de gagner je cite
plus qu'une poignée de fans durant
toutes ces années
est ce que nintendo n'a pas un peu
sous-estimé l'intérêt que portent des
joueurs à ce personnage
carla résultats des sondages sont la
chine car roule est attendu par une
majorité de joueurs et ce majoro c'est
avant tout un jeu de fin de service
king carole peut faire vendre alors king
krule sera probablement dans le prochain
casting mais en dehors de cet aspect
marketing le choix de ce personnage me
paraît tout à fait cohérent il viendrait
compléter la liste très maigre des
représentants de l'univers donkey kong
mais également celle des méchants au
casting général lorsqu'on fait la
balance on se rend compte qu'ils sont
tout de même particulièrement
minoritaires tinga route pourrait lancer
sa couronne tira voteront blond comme
dans donkey kong country 2 ou bien même
se battre avec des gants de boxe comme
dans donkey kong 64
c'est un personnage qui offre beaucoup
de possibilités d'attaqué qui
s'intégrerait très bien à l'ambiance un
peu folle dans super smash bros qui plus
est d'une quelconque d'être absolument
pas une licence à l'abandon en témoigne
la sortie d'un tropicale free / switch
pour conclure j'aimerais rajouter qu'en
plus de tout ça avec king caroulle on
aurait quand même un crocodile dans ce
match un crocodile bon sens
rex xenoblade chronicles fut un réel
succès sur wii sorti en 2011 en europe
avec des notes frôlant la perfection et
nintendo en a bien profité en mettant
shulk dans smash bros wii ou un portage
fait même créé sur new 3ds dans ce
dernier est en décembre 2010 est une
suite est sortie
zeno blade chronicles 2 avec des notes
toujours aussi grandiose le pense qu'on
peut donc quasiment l'affirmer mais il
ya de très très grandes chances qu'un
second personnage de xenoblade fasse son
apparition après tout fire emblem seyant
très bien marché nintendo n'a pas hésité
à rajouter lucina et corinne alors
pourquoi pas des nobles et qui marche
tout aussi bien sachez que xenoblade
accumulé plus de 100000 vente en à peine
trois jours après sa sortie pour rester
donc dans la cohérence de nintendo rex
pourrait bien faire son apparition étant
le protagoniste principal de ce second
opus étant un combattant de base son
gameplay ne serait pas difficile à
imaginer
il combattrait avec sa célèbre l'âme
pirae utiliserait d'autres accessoires
pour se défendre comme par exemple son
petit grappin comme recover pour éviter
de tomber ou attraper des ennemis un
petit peu comme link aussi un terme
tournant particulièrement autour du feu
étant le type principal de pire à
peut-être même qu'un gameplay serait
alors adapté pour que nous voyons rex et
pire à combattre ensemble sur certains
move comme night clubbers se met en
moins poussées cependant la chose qui me
fait douter par rapport à sa venue dans
ce match serait que les deux
protagonistes de xenoblade seraient des
garçons ni à pourrait être alors la
seconde option si nintendo souhaite
diversifier les genres ou bien nintendo
pourrait alors faire appel à un autre
personnage provenant du premier
xenoblade
mais je ne pense pas personnellement
n'oublions pas que nintendo se sert
énormément de ce match
en termes de marketing après tout vite a
gagné énormément popularité et quand il
est arrivé dans ce match comme dizaine
mlt dans la première vidéo ou m rex
donnerait un coup de pub encore plus
gros pour xenoblade et notamment
xenoblade chronicles 2
je suis quasiment sûr qu'il y sera
[Musique]
risque pas mal de monde aimerait voir un
personnage du jeu indépendant under tel
dans la liste des personnages de ce
match et pas mal d'autres sont
totalement contre cette idée le succès
du jeu de toby fox est accompagné d'une
communauté de fans très active et
productive sur internet
cependant cette même communauté n'est
pas vue d'un très bon et par tous
certaines personnes ne pensant
simplement pas que le jeu mérite son
succès d'autres pointant du doigt la
mentalité de certains fans
ce qu'il faut se dire c'est que par les
donneurs tél en prenant position fera
bondir l'un des deux camps mais qu'il
est nécessaire de le faire dans le cadre
de cette vidéo ne serait ce que pour
briser le tabou autour de ce jeu donc
c'est parti
regarde t elle a été annoncée sur
switcher via le nintendo direct du 8
mars celui dans lequel a également été
diffusé le premier trailer du futur
smash bros l'arrivée d'un jeu sûr switch
ne rend pas éligible ses personnages
pour intégrer le casting de notre jeu de
baston
on est bien d'accord mais tommy fox le
créateur dunderdale a fait un tweet pour
le moins mystérieux libyen que son jeu
va arriver sur switch avant de parler de
smash bros il ya sûrement une touche
d'ironie dans son message
car il sait bien que ses fans veulent
voir du rhône dorkel dans smash bros
mais n'y aurait-il pas autre chose
d'autre part comme je l ai déjà dit la
communauté hundert elle est passionnée
envers le jeu nintendo pourrait très
bien se saisir de cette opportunité
commerciale en intégrant du contenu
under tel dans smash bros mais bon ces
arguments sont extrêmement minces et
plusieurs éléments viennent les
contrebalancer pour commencer la date de
sortie de nortel sur switch n'est pas
annoncée à moins que quelque chose
d'étrange ne se trame
si cette date est inconnue c'est que le
jeu ne sera pas disponible avant un bon
moment
or on sait bien que ce match sort en
2018 si un tel sort après smash bros
il y a très peu de chances de voir des
personnages de ce jeu dessus nortel n'a
que ce portage sur switch kg raccroche à
nintendo serty toby fox est un grand fan
de la licence hairband on retrouve dans
nortel une patte plutôt proche du jeu
sur certains aspects mais ça c'est pas
un argument fiable sinon n'importe quel
fan game reprenant des licences de
nintendo se retrouverait dans smash bros
intégrer le casting de ce match si tu ne
fais pas partie de l'univers nintendo et
que tu n'as pas de partenariat avec la
firme à moins d'être appelée cloud et
d'être
ni connu jeu vidéo bah c'est peu
probable et c'est là que la question se
pose la popularité de nortel est elle
suffisante pour que le jeu soit
considéré comme une icône du jeu vidéo
vous avez deux heures c'est bien là la
grande inconnue de cette équation donc
aujourd'hui concrètement le seul moyen
de voir ce match accueillir hundert elle
se serait sans doute que nintendo
refasse des dlc et demande aux gens de
voter pour de nouveaux personnages après
sur un coup de folie ça peut passer et
qui sait et et omra bon allez on va
prendre un petit risque pour être tout à
fait honnête avec vous je ne suis pas un
grand fan de bomberman ai jamais
vraiment beaucoup joué et je trouve que
le personnage manque un peu de charisme
bomberman c'est une licence populaire
mais qui a connu un véritable déclin
alors comme ça ça semble mal parti et
pourtant la société qui a créé bomberman
ce n'est pas n'importe qui puisqu'il
s'agit d'une aide sunsoft et hudson soft
c'est une entreprise qui a collaboré
avec pas mal de groupes et notamment
nintendo c'est la boîte qui assure et
développement de la série mario party et
ce jusqu'à l'épisode 8 compris soit par
les autres mario party qui ont suivi et
bien tout simplement parce que hudson
soft était dans une situation financière
difficile et qu'elle a été totalement
rachetées par konami en 2011
mais dans tous les cas c'est une
relation beaucoup plus étroits puisque
celle que j'imaginais entre le sud aux
créateurs de bomberman et big n
mais puisque bomberman appartient
aujourd'hui à konami konami parleurs
sont sept hideo kojima le papa de metal
gear et vice-président de ladite
entreprise qui avait réussi à convaincre
sakurai d'intégrer solid snake au
casting de smash bros à la surprise
générale
pas de scrutin à ce moment là la seule
force des relations semblent avoir
influencé l'intégration de ce personnage
aussi malgré les meilleurs arguments que
nous pourrons développer ne savons pas
tout de ce qui se passe dans les
coulisses à cela nous pouvons ajouter
que malgré un accueil critique mitigé
les ventes de super bomberman air sur
switch se sont très bien porte à la
sortie du jeu et ce dernier réussit
toujours à maintenir l'intérêt des
joueurs à travers des mises à jour
régulières
enfin et pour finir même si la licence
n'est pas au top de sa forme
bomberman reste une icône du jeu vidéo
symbole et souvenirs pour beaucoup de
parties endiablées contre ses amis ce
personnage incarne à merveille lisez de
la baston plein de folie
il apparaît d'ailleurs dans plusieurs
fans games et dispose d'un large
éventail de possibilités pour ces
différentes attaques
c'est pourquoi je pense que bomberman
mériterait tout à fait sa place à côté
de mega man et pacman alors il est vrai
que j'adorerais voir crash bandicoot sur
cette licence
mais je pense que c'est encore trop
récent pour arriver dans ce match
sachant qu'en plus le portage est
annoncée sur switch mais si certains ne
savent pas crash sera aussi sur pc xbox
one pareil ensuite pour mario odyssée
est ce que le gameplay de mario va-t-il
totalement changé pour inclure les
fonctionnalités avec capi ou bien
sera-t-il ici comme un nouveau
personnage comme dr mario voire peut
être même le remplacer ou peut-être
carrément ne pas être présent du tout
nintendo s'ouvre enfin au monde est de
plus en plus de personnages peuvent
faire leur apparition
je suis certain que plusieurs d'entre
vous sont convaincus cas perso de dark
souls sera présent dans smash bros
switch
mais il ne faut pas oublier que ce sont
surtout des personnages de nintendo
prévu sur switch et tous les personnages
que l'on partage son nez de notre
imagination et notre heim
si un personnage d'une autre licence
arrive sur smash bros c'est qu'il est
très quémander par les fans mais surtout
que les relations entre les deux
entreprises sont bonnes et stratégiques
on aurait pu aussi parler de riley que
tout le monde quémande mais il était
déjà un boss dans brawl je suis pas sûr
que nintendo le prévoit pour le prochain
smash
enfin est-ce que smash bros est un
portage ou bien un nouveau jeu je pense
au fond de moi qu'il est un nouvel opus
le teaser proposé je me souviens pas
avoir vu poken dxo mario kart 8 de luxe
annoncé avec une telle puissance et un
tel suspense en toute fin de stream
en tout cas ce que je souhaite par
dessus tout c'est un nouvel émissaire
subspatial qui a marqué mon début
d'adolescence et je suis certain qu'à
mode histoire existera nous ne sommes
pas là pour vous dire que nous avons
raison nous sommes juste des passionnés
de ce match et nous aimons rêver on
cherche à transmettre ceci tout en étant
le plus probable pour les futurs
nouveaux personnages
n'hésitez pas à aller voir la chaîne de
mes amis nous et les maltais qui font un
excellent travail sur pokémon mélange de
l'esp l'est et de youtube poop c'est
vraiment incroyablement drôle et bien
monté je vous recommande leur chaîne
et il me semble d'ailleurs que je joue
dans le prochain épisode alors foncez
[Rires]
merci à ceux qui laisseront un pouce
bleus et qui partageront la vidéo suivez
moi sur twitter c'est très important
vous aurez le droit à des exclus c'est
et argo rock et que le liner soit avec
vous j'ai hâte de vous affronter sur
smash bros 5
[Musique]